Good morning, everyone.
We are getting ready for our first full day in California.
For this trip in March. I went to this gluten free bakery,
and it was absolutely incredible.
I haven't stopped thinking about it.
And now I used to collab with them,
which is so fun.
After we eat breakfast, we're going to go to the pier in Santa Monica.
Walking up and down the pier,
taking lots of film pictures.
The weather here is absolutely unreal.
It's so beautiful.
Then tonight we're actually getting dinner with Dean and Catherine.
It'll be the butlers and the brawlers. Tonight.
We found things in the works.
Tomorrow, Jake and I are going to the Warner Brothers Studio Tour.
So I can't decide what I should wear.
I could wear these cute little shorts.
This white tank. Did wear a dress.
This is the one that I was thinking about wearing.
Very summer. Maybe I wear this dress and then change.
Would be stupid to wear this dress and then change.
You guys know that I'm absolutely obsessed with fears, nature.
I cannot say enough good things about this rare beauty product.
I think that it's one of her most underrated products.
I never have seen anybody talking about it.
Is her glossy bomb. This is the color.
Nearly apricot.
Stunning. And this is what the whole fit looks like.
I think it's so cute.